الوقت هو المعادل الكبير في المستشفيات
في جميع أنحاء تركيا وليس هناك ما يكفي
منه هنا في مدينة أضنة في
مستشفى التدريس والبحث حيث يأتي المرضى
بكسور مع أي نوع من
الإصابات
يتكون من أنسجة فقدان العرج
يسحق الأنسجة المفقودة و
مروحية صدمة الدماغ الدكتور سليمان هو رئيس
الأركان هنا في غضون دقائق ، تم
استدعاء فريق الصدمات مرة أخرى وصلت طائرة هليكوبتر أخرى.
التي أتت إلى هنا خلال
الأيام السبعة الماضية ، عمل
جراحو العظام وجراحو الأعصاب على
إجراء عملياتهم لمدة سبعة أيام متتالية ،
وهذا هو أكبر
مستشفى للصدمات في منطقة الزلزال ، حيث
يتحرك الأطباء بسرعة بهدف رعاية
هذه المرأة البالغة من العمر 26 عامًا والتي تعاني
كليتها من الفشل  من شيء
يعرف باسم متلازمة كراش ،
تم إطلاق الكثير من السموم في دمها بعد أن تم
تحرير طرفها أخيرًا ، وستحتاج إلى
غسيل كلوي ناشئ
مرارًا وتكرارًا من
منطقة الزلزال ، ولحسن الحظ أخيرًا جعلها
هنا للحصول على المساعدة
وواحدة مع القصة الأكثر روعة.  لقد
سمعنا هذه العائلة الجميلة المكونة من خمسة أفراد
شعرت أن الأرض تهتز ثم شاهدت ما
يحدث لا يمكن تصوره على
ارتفاع سبعة طوابق ، ولم يكن بإمكانهم
فعل أي شيء سوى مشاهدة الطفل بيرغر البالغ من العمر ثمانية أشهر
وقد اندفع بطريقة ما من
النافذة من خمسة طوابق إلى الأرض
ثم انظر إلى ما حدث لمبنىهم الذي سوي بالأرض
بعد أن حوصرت نفسها لمدة
14 ساعة تقريبًا وبدأت في الحفر وكشط الأنقاض
بحثًا عن أي علامة على الإطلاق
على أن طفلتها كانت لا تزال على
قيد الحياة
وفي تلك المرحلة في اليوم الخامس كنا
اعتقدنا أننا سنرى جسدها الذي لا حياة له ،
ولكن بعد ذلك حدث شيء مذهل ،
أظهر لهم شخص ما هذا المنشور على Twitter
في البداية لم يكونوا متأكدين ، لكن هذه
الطفلة كانت تشبه إلى حد كبير ابنتها كما
ترى ، لم يكن لدينا أي فكرة أنها قد تم
إنقاذها في الفوضى  أنقذ السامري الصالح
الفتاة ونُقلت جواً هنا
مكسورة وضربت ساقها اليسرى
محطمة
في جمجمتها المكسورة.